depuis mardi une vaste campagne a été
lancée pour inciter tous les internautes
à cesser les téléchargements de cd ou de
dvd les majors du disque ou du film font
même appel à des sociétés qui traque les
pirates sur la toile et vous allez le
voir quelques secondes suffisent pour
les repérer sylvain thiry nikkei
driessche cet homme traque les pirates
internautes son métier agents
assermentés à la protection des
programmes en temps réel
il va identifier l'internaute qui
télécharge illégalement de la musique
sur le site gaza donc là je joue casa
comme le fait n'importe quel internaute
on a et donc ils téléchargent une des
chansons du catalogue son ordinateur
dialogue alors directement avec
l'ordinateur du pirate qui propose le
morceau le piège peut se refermer je
mens immédiatement la machine se met à
dialoguer avec la machine de la personne
qui fait qu'ils proposent le fichier est
donc je peux identifier son adresse ip
prend l'adresse ip c'est un numéro
attribué à chaque ordinateur
dès que l'on se connecte à internet la
machine trace donc le chemin parcouru
entre la machine qui me sert à constater
et la machine qui propose les phisheurs
téléchargement ici on s'aperçoit que
c'est un abonné wanna do qui se situe à
rennes à partir de ce moment là il me
suffit d'aller voir wanadoo et de
demander à qui a été attribuée cette
adresse ip au moment où j'ai dressé mon
procès verbal de constat
mais les fournisseurs d'accès internet
accepte t il de donner l'identité de la
personne qui se cache derrière
l'ordinateur
chez free on a souvent été sollicité et
pour cause il compte plus d'un million
cinq cent mille abonnés et leur réponse
est toujours la même car réglementée
tous nos abonnés sont anonymes sur notre
réseau nous levons l'anonymat c'est à
dire qu'une des wallons l'identité de
nos abonnés uniquement sur décision
judiciaire c'est-à-dire sur décision
d'un juge et free a déjà été obligées de
divulguer des identités d'internautes
des affaires comme celle là olivier
iteanu avocat spécialisé en nouvelles
technologies en a déjà plaidé
de toute façon pour lui les 23 millions
d'internautes français sont tous des
cybercriminels et les attaquer en
justice ne réglera certainement pas le
problème des téléchargements illicites
pratique et un usage qui a une ampleur
considérable et face à ça il faut se
demander à quoi sert la loi et si on
pense pouvoir résoudre le problème par
des exemples face à un phénomène d'une
telle ampleur
je pense qu'on se trompe pourtant
l'industrie du disque a annoncé qu'elles
allaient massivement attaqués ses
internautes
mais face aux 16 millions de
téléchargements de chansons par jour en
france ce combat risque de leur coûter
très cher